j'ai déjà fait de la prison donc ça va
weight
au film enter dolo djezzy son dernier
album par exemple été pourri personne
n'écoute
quoique instagram dans l'année je suis
sûre brut lourd bretois sur la pochette
de dolce vita georges fed voit
exactement qui mord à minneapolis
on a tous abandonnés et tout sépare la
police pourquoi avant des noms mais
parce que les gens me faisait rire à pau
c'était des carrés noirs et à manifester
mais c'était que trendy que trendy bahia
qu'on en parle là aujourd'hui
quelqu'un se soucie de lui quelqu'un
souci des décades plis qui sont sortis
sous caution et qui sont en liberté
personne n'en parle ils sont juste posé
d'écart et c'est on le dit dans une
chanson
ils font la guerre avec des chars on
pose des carrés sur un star et toi tu
fais quoi du coup à part des des
chansons c'est à dire tu dénonce le fait
que les gens s'engagent de manière
trendy comme tu le dis quoi se
défaussant galop en mois de deux de tous
âges en parle depuis mes débuts
j'en parle vraiment mais ça a quand même
relancé aux etats unis une vague de
protestations blacklight matters dont on
a beaucoup parlé
blatter les quatre flics sur liberté
donc super les carrés mais les mecs qui
sont en liberté
personne n'en parle à personne non pas
je veux dire y'a pas dessus maintenant
s'ils nous font dire où il en parle plus
en tout cas moi je n'entends pas parler
en tout cas j'entends parler que de
vaccins et de masques
cette touche intimement j'imagine bon
moi j'ai un pan du g1 noire pendue
tétouan dans le dos avec 40
sud-américain enfin des états unis qui
sont qui pose devant donc nous sommes
touche
est-ce que tu as suivi ce qui s'est
passé quand même en france dans le
sillage de la mort de georges floyd il
ya eu comme un renouveau de la
mobilisation notamment le mouvement de
justice pour adam à toi d'avoir et de la
récup
s'il faut attendre six fois ton à un
autre décès pour parler de damas est pas
sincère et puis à des combats il ya des
combats à mener il ya des mais les
combats c'est bien de les mener si on
peut les gagner on dit dans une chanson
le flic tueur d'alain traoré sera
acquitté jamais la france ne va mettre
en prison
ces soldats faut être réaliste je te
parlais d'acea traoré la soeur de m à à
l'instant qu'elle regarde tu portes
abu shreh avec son combat c'est noble a
perdu son frère c'est normal que voilà
elle ne fait pas de poster des quarts et
je comprends tout à fait mais je pense
que c'est perdu d'avancé malheureusement
nouveaux bassins pessimiste réaliste
réaliste - donc osé de la france aimez
là ou quittez là j'ai vu que mes pages
et l'équité des fois c'est des fois
c'est ça qu'il faut faire un faux pas
être n'at il fait croire qu'on va
changer tout un tout un pays tout un
tout un continent
vous êtes rallye justement des fois faut
me grey comme les comme les animaux donc
ça y est on y est dixième album le
dernier l'ultime opus de vous va il
trace déjà pourquoi ultra ultra sommes
définis un peu j'ai pas vraiment de jeu
pas vraiment de milieux ce soit je suis
je suis très très gentil soit très très
méchant
j'ai pas de l'ultra quoi chez les
extrêmes dans les extrêmes et alors la
pochette elle m'a intrigué cette
pochette on tâte un regard qui est qui
se plongent dans les yeux des forces
entre regard ultra c'est donc tout
donner l'impression que tu regardais
aussi quelque part ta carrière tout ce
qui vient de se dérouler droit dans
l'eau c'est tout l'avenir
moi je fais pas de c'est pas la
farandole ma musique c'est je parle de
je parle de ma vie de ce que je pense
d'eux des gens de trucs de société c'est
c'est la réalité
voilé serré je me trouve sérieusement
musique mes textes y sont j'élèverai
punchline jeudi des vraies choses tu à
44 ans en 2002 sur ton album temps mort
dans le morceau on m'a dit tu disait
heureux si j'atteins la trentaine à
l'époque j'avais 25 ans donc c'est un
horizon assez court 50 proches est-ce
que ça t'étonne d'être toujours là au
plus tard oui je crois que j'aille à
inguiniel j'ai un record mondial je
crois vu mon âge et vu le futur numéro
je pense que dans le monde n'y a pas de
rapports comme en accomplissant djezzy
son dernier album par exemple l'été
pourri bonne écoute
donc je crois je suis le seul les selles
donc moi je suis étonné bien sûr
quant à quentin incertaine à ça ça pour
moi ça sert à rien de continuer si tu es
plus la course
enfin moi je suis un compétiteur donc si
je suis plus si je suis pas sur le
podium j'arrête quoi j'ai longtemps fait
et ça va peut être faire bizarre de
lâcher la compet justement laisser la
compote
il ya plus de compet donc je suis ni
comme il faut et
on continue on produit d'autres artistes
on a un peu en guinée jean zidane au
real madrid quoi et tu as travaillé sur
l'album pendant le confine enfin j'ai
même pas dans quelle mesure tu as été
confinés où panino qu'on fait l'europe
note that you know confinement pas pour
moi ok mais on ne t'a pas eu ces trucs
pas mal d'artistes ont eu d'être enfermé
pendant deux mois pour certains ça a été
dit et j'ai déjà fait de la prison donc
ça va ouais on lui demande ce boulot
c'est un peu plus conforté moi j'imagine
mais je peux comprendre que ça
abbas et déstabilisant on parlait de la
france tout à l'heure tous rapports un
peu à la france je voudrais parler de la
langue française qui est ton outils
d'écriture qu'elle rapportait à cette
langue
déjà les customiser déjà bien bien
customiser mais bon c'est une très très
belle langue tous ceux qui parlent mal
et étudiants l'anglais avec dix mots tu
t'en sors dix mots tu peux plus par un
album mais wells est beaucoup plus riche
que l'anglais est alors encore plus
riche après que vous va soit passé
puisque de valider au calme garde la
pêche
c'est une fierté pour tous que toutes
ces expressions elles soient restés et
qui occupe à jour j'aime ça
le nouveau commandant larousse ou dans
les nouveaux dictionnaires ya des doit y
avoir un verre quelque part c'est une
fierté que ce soir après sinon c'est
masséna suns et samantha été banni à vie
d'instagram pris perpète
ouais pourquoi parce que je n'ai pas
suivi les règles j'ai posté le cud
siandso en tout cas entre parenthèses
j'ai pris sur instagram
j'ai été banni pour l'avoir posté mais
je les prie de chez eux
mais j'accepte j'ai enfreint les règles
et pas de problème taxi à l'aise urgent
insulter les gens je marche je disais
j'ai poussé mes coups de gueule brémond
banimmo bonne et moi mon truc c'est la
musique
oui ce qui est important c'est la
musique c'est ultra après j'ai fait le
con sur instagram on emballe une bonne
option pour moi c'était des bars il a du
coup été en promo de son dernier album
tu as perdu tout compte instagram tu
regrettes pas un peu au dessus sur brut
tissus bruts lourds brut main dans ce
dixième et dernier album ultra tu
chantes de plus en plus le chant c'était
presque un tabou dans le rap quand a
commencé je vais citer pas si j'avais ma
chance et cher loire depuis longtemps
musicalement c'est comme dans les jeux
vidéo là quand tu débloquer un niveau
débloquer le niveau de vie de niveau
chant j'ai débloqué le niveau mariah
carey ça m'a permis de faire des numéros
en tout temps parce que la mélodie aussi
ça apporte autre chose et ce qui viendra
mais audi succès entre guillemets ça
casse un peu la barrière de la langue
c'était difficile pour toi de te mettre
à chanter enfin j'imagine que quand on
l'a jamais fait c'est aussi se mettre à
nu côté de mon passé comme le rap cgc
c'est mon pote malachie faisait de
l'auto tune je connaissais pas mais
enfin si je connaissais j'écoutais dans
le ragga le rail etc
il lui l'utiliser
j'ai fait un feat avec lui c'est la
première fois que j'utilisais et voilà
comme pour l'heure je me suis découvert
un nouveau talent je me suis rendu
compte que j'arrivais à chanter j'avais
les mélodies et vu qu'on a une bille la
france ait éclaté qu'il ya personnes
âgées ça m'a permis de faire mes refrain
tout seul il y avait personne à appeler
si je mets un refrain r'n'b aujourd'hui
j'appelle qui rappelle toi même ouais tu
pourrais chanter sur you tube
bien sûr ouais je le fais souvent avec
un pays dont elle aime chanter aussi ta
fille non aux équipes c'est une artiste
elle chantait morceau on va bien sûr
même les paroles d'un gris qu'elle parle
très peu français
c'est pas la france est un peu un petit
elle apprend à l'école avec moi un peu
mais et commence d'ailleurs il paraît
que tu as pris des cours de piano
non j'ai tenté mais j'ai pas la patience
ça passe à 1 2 et non bah je m'étais dit
je m'étais fait des plans sur la comète
je me suis dit si un jour ma fille et
chante et qui a fait le madison square
garden charles vers dar el au piano mais
bon j'ai fait trois leçons j'ai
abandonné et elle m a lâché elle veut
pas prendre de leçons donc tu vas c'est
tombé à l'eau pour l'instant les soirs
garden on va attendre qu est ce que tu
es ce que tu vas faire dans les
prochaines ceni ont produit beaucoup
d'artistes
on a les vêtements je travaille sur une
série aussi c'est bien avancé
tu peux nous en dire un peu plus voilà
j'ai travaillé sur une série en tant que
producteur saison producteur acteur
hockey par un premier rôle
tu es déjà joué les lecteurs donc oui
atteint dans les clips non c'est quelque
chose d'autant j'effectue refusé des
rôles
non c'est pas un rêve c'est le cinéma
j'aime bien mais c'est comme la musique
ou que ce soit je veux pas en faire pour
en faire je vais pas faire du
shakespeare ou pièce de théâtre faut
qu'il fasse un truc qui me qui
m'intéressent qui me corresponde qui me
donc du coup en étant producteur je me
fais mon rôle sur mesure où je me sens à
l'aise ce que j'ai pas la prétention
d'être leonardo dicaprio et c'est pas le
but donc j'ai mon rôle dedans mais c'est
pas un premier rôle un roulé et à mesure
à ton image de fumier way de chimie de
fumier un rôle de fumier cette série fo
demandé à emmanuel encore une fois
battre on se serait tourné en france
donc en partie si ça rouvre ici nous
envoie pas posé de 23 ça je pourrais un
temps ce qui serait possible qu'un jour
tu te réinstalle en france sous le
régime actuel non je pense pas façon je
suis pas je suis pas attaché à un pays
un passeport ou une religion
moi je prends mon bateau et je navigue
ça libère la liberté je m'en fous d'être
français américains africains pour moi
ça compte en disant que tu es passé par
londres avant de je veux les en beaucoup
d'endroits où j'ai fait les états unis
j'ai fait des 3g fait londres j'ai fait
le los angeles j'ai fait la planète elle
est grande quand on commence à voyager
tu parlais de détroit détroit c'est ya
les adolescents c'est ça en était la
première 14 avec les états unis raconte
au site écolo c'était comme dans un film
comme si j'étais rentré dans ma télé
j'aimais beaucoup la culture noire
américaine la musique etc
arrivée à détroit c'est 80% de black est
bas alors j'étais dans une famille black
j'écoutais j'étais correspondant logique
côté du rap gens s'habillent comme moi
enfin moi je m'habiller comme le plus
tôt j'ai kiffé cities justement à
l'école j'ai fait highschool en histoire
justement et de donner le choix tu
pouvais choisir tel est ce que tu as les
étudier moi j'avais pris l'histoire de
des noirs aux états unis et ses râles
les esclavages non c'est une bonne
expérience
est-ce que c'était la première fois que
tu te retrouvais dans un contexte où il
y avait une certaine fierté d'être noir
non non ne pas une fierté c'était juste
que je me sentais comme tout le monde en
fait pas des visages et par ont regardé
pas ma coupe de cheveux ma couleur de
peau la manière dont je m'habille et
chérie tu peux le sortait libre en fête
7 on a souffert en france c'est quand tu
étais jeune adolescente on a souffert du
regard qui était posé sur toi bien sûr
bien sûr surtout à l'époque comme c'est
dans ma chanson avant michael jackson et
l'arrivée dans la drogue je me souviens
qu'on les [ __ ] n'était pas à la mode
quand j'étais petit pas vraiment le noir
la télé avec eddie murphy et les sols et
les noirs y faisait bas est balayé il
est évidemment nous prient et alexandre
donc à détroit tu as découvert autre
chose quoi j'étais comme comme si
j'étais au sénégal elle a dix ans
j'étais à l'île de gorée donc tu veux
justement parlé du sénégal la plupart de
ceux qui nous regardent le savent
tu es né d'une mère française et d'un
père sénégalais mbaye me sens que si ton
cousin c'est mon cousin où aller faut
que tu as choisi ces pseudos bas c'était
un peu mon premier contact entre
guillemets c'est là c'est mon le cousin
avec qui je traînais la première fois
que tu allais c'était pour faire le
relais j'ai choisi son nom plutôt que
m'a appelé je fais pas m6 machin je bois
est alors tout à l'heure tu et vous quel
à l'île de gorée île de man avec kim au
large de dakar alors justement je
voulais tant parler parce que je pense
que tu as vécu une expérience assez
similaire à ce que celle que moi j'ai
vécu petit quand je suis allé sur cette
île tout le monde pense tout le monde
décide sur tous ces thèmes et et je sais
pas pour toi à moi de le fait d'être
métis je tolère encore moins le racisme
puisque je suis un mélange donc je me
dis donc pour boire c'est encore plus
horrible de travail alors à cesson
j'explique ce juste du coup pour ceux
qui connaîtraient pas à gorée c'est une
île que au large de dakar où il ya une
maison qui s'appelle la maison des
esclaves qu on peut visiter et qui était
l'endroit d'où les esclaves partait pour
les etats-unis se remettent la côte
il y en a plein ouest pour ce qu'ils
soient pas c'est resté l'endroit un peu
symbolique de 2 ca de l'ordre
est ce que tu peux me décrire déjà cet
endroit pour ceux qui ne le connaissent
pas et et qu'est ce que ça t'a fait en
fait quand il ya les gamins pour la fin
fois qu'est ce que tu as ressenti
c'était la preuve que l'être humain est
un fumier un grand fumier est la preuve
de voilà quand tu passes le truc dans ta
dans ta tête et tu te rends vraiment
compte de ce que c'est et de des
horreurs que ça représente
voilà peut-être traumatisé entre
guillemets que du dégoût du de la haine
l'incompréhension du cellulaire et
imagine les viols les tortures les fous
et la vente
prends ton enfant le ventre laisse
tomber dedans par l'état c'est même dur
à imaginer quoi cette maison des
esclaves que tu décrivait à l'instant on
la voit au tout début du clip de dkr dkr
ça a été un sacré moment dans ta
carrière je pense est-ce que comment
elle était reçue au sénégal cette
chanson bas bien je suis moi j'ai mon
intérêt manquerait plus que ça qu'ils
aiment pas est-ce que tu as eu des
retours particulier est ce que quand tu
te retournes au sénégal on regarde le
clip tout le monde dans un climat et
bien sûr je pense que c'est validé je
pense titre considère comme un poète
comme je maîtrise des mots si quoi la
poésie c'est ça c'est joué avec les mots
la rime
c'est à dire des choses avec peu de mots
est horrible c'est presque des maths
même je me projette quand j'écris c'est
que des salles et punch lines et que des
des événements des lieux tutu voyage
pour ça que j'aime à la poésie s'il veut
dire que quand tu écris tu te mets dans
un espèce d'état particulier ccg crée
des images en fait les situations et
c'est ça qui m'a en fait c'est ça qui
m'a parlé dans la poésie c'est ça qui
m'a parlé dans leur apprends j'écoute
est naze le premier album de nazes ou de
billes la manière d'écrire pareil
c'était quand j'écoutais j'aurais
l'impression d'être dans leur quartier
ou dans l'ordre ça qui me plaît dans
l'écriture et quel monde tu t'es dit en
fait c'est mon truc
bah quand j'ai vu que j'étais plus que
je vais débuter xt et que j'étais plus
fort que mes potes qui étaient à fond
depuis combien de temps j'ai explosé
direct sans faire exprès je me suis dit
ah je suis pas mon gré
mais surtout après le crime paie qu'on a
eu le retour des du public quoi les gens
nous ont acclamé comme si c'était une
révolution un peu on l'avait fait sans
prétention mais j'ai senti qu'il y avait
quelque chose soit dans ma couleur en
2010 tu disais je te cite je pense que
tu sais ce que je vais citer j'ai
toujours eu un manque à combler je dois
tout à une femme c'est qui cette femme
bamert ta mère elle m'a élevé tout seul
elle est très courageuse solide faire un
exemple quoi elle est tout ce que tu
fais ouais elle en dit quoi
elle te fait des retombées pas leur
ballet m'vila mais elle pleure parce que
c'est trop dur ça la met à la mer qui si
trop dur bah les paroles mais pas parce
qu elle s est squale de quoi je parle
donc ça la touche quoi est ce dû coûter
enfants ils sont américains
ils ont la nationalité moi je m'en
disent que toi tu leur transmettaient 2
des cultures d'origine tu as grandi en
france tél oui vous lis un peu avant de
dormir saisi français ça je te dis mais
n'y a pas de français ouais nous gardant
les études et scottish tu as des hommes
et des des comportements je leur
transmets ce qui est bien on marchera
pas frappé sa soeur j'ai la musique même
chose dans sa soeur n'ont pas de de nous
écouter de ceux qui passent pas trop de
temps sur les sur le le téléphone
j'essaie de la leur effet regardez
avatar j'ai pas le temps après je vois
des choses simulent des choses qui me
semble normal d'être juste d'être
respectueux pas être fainéant de faire
de l'exercice
je leur transmets pas de la religion et
cetera
la petite souris j'ai annulé donc si
c'est la perdre une dent j'ai voulu
faire les buy de petites souris machin
je me suis pas réveillé je vais oublier
de mettre le truc qui m'a duale est
parvenu julia elle est tombée c'est du
boulot y'a pas ils ont eu une jeunesse
qui très différente de celle que toi tu
as eue a battu considère que c'est des
privilégiés bah oui comment est-ce que
tu t'assures que tes enfants quand ils
vont grandir et bien les pieds sur terre
en iran comme des enfants des gens
sortaient les enfants de booba nous
offrant soit ça ça joue pas si j'étais
aussi si j'étais en tendance peut-être
mais c'est n'y a pas de booba à miami a
pas de bobards je vais la publication
short claquettes et a pas de bois est
alors toi tu fait vachement du sport
dans la halle de musculation bond au
sport en général
même sur la version vinyle durant trois
ans comme d'hab on te voit torse nu les
bras écartés de muscu le tübitak un
rapport à tout le maton corps tout
simplement tu troubles bon en tout cas
j'essaie de montres m'entretenir
je trouve moi moi je sais que certains
cette session je me supporter
mais le sport c'est plus c'est pas que
c'est pas que physique c'est aussi
mental surtout alors j'ai une dernière
question d'un ultra ya un morceau qui
s'appelle mona lisa tu dis dedans je
suis tellement dans le futur elle était
tellement loin que le futur est derrière
tellement que le pire est derrière moi
bah du coup si tu es si loin dans le
futur il ressemble à quoi
le futur dit nous qu'est ce qui nous
attend ah qu'est ce qui nous attend qu
est ce qui nous attend franchement je
peux pas te répondre c'est tellement
incertain mais je partirai en pirate
debout